[Music]
thanks for the warning
[Music]
all right
let's rock and roll
[Music]
i blow it a bit harder hopefully it
expands a bit more
[Music]
ready
[Music]
i think it just got too heavy for how
thin it is
pretty cool
[Music]
[Music]
how do you put little things in it so
you heat the glass up and then you join
bits of colour inside and it
droops and stretches through the glass
they're awesome
[Music]
i'm going to thicken up a handle so i
can hold it properly
it will be used later as well
and what are we making
just a small swan
small spawn
your four goes well
[Music]
that's a bit thin
do the job
do the same on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just going to separate where the
head and the body is going to be
[Music]
the thing you gotta remember about this
is to make sure one side is always
closed or
one side's always open
it's gonna pop over us
[Music]
that part's going to be its head that's
it's got this body i'm going to pull its
neck now
again i'll get my excuses out early i've
not done one of these for about two
years
[Music]
it's starting to take shape a little bit
this part's going to be one of their
little wings
[Music]
trick is getting them even on both sides
[Music]
that's as much of a wing again
[Music]
i'm gonna put a little dawn for his eyes
[Music]
actually stand up as well
[Music]
we'll get it we will get it to stand
there we go
if you look through on a polaroscope
you'll see a lot of
stress around all the joints where it's
been manipulated so where's the polaris
go
over in the corner
[Music]
all glass once it's been heated or
change shape it has a lot of thermal
stress
that's why it needs to go in the oven to
get it to its annealing point which is
560 degrees and then it cools down very
slowly
that just takes all the stress out of it
so if you look
through this lens you can see a lot of
blues purples yellows
quite a spectrum to be honest
yeah look at that
there's quite a few colors even from the
head
oh look at that right next to the wing
so those are stress points this is all
stress so once it's been in the oven and
annealed all that should just look as
clear as it does when you're not looking
on this
a lot of stress
it's a stress swan
[Music]
that's one
nice swan
no pun intended
bethenny promise
if she ever took the lid off the coffin
to reveal the mummy we would be invited
and guess what
today it's happening